[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so sell israel
heute gibt es ein richtig leckeres und
sommerliches selbst wir werden formaten
so groß zu bereiten und weist eine soße
aus tomaten
die varianten mit gekrümmten auberginen
stücken und es ist wirklich super lecker
und vor allem super einfach ihr könnt
dem wirklich rezept als grundrezept
nehmen und dann wirklich abwandeln wie
ihr möchtet
ich zeige euch jetzt mal die zutaten
hier vorne und dann starten wir direkt
für das auberginen tomaten profis zwei
opfer schienen bei stangen
staudensellerie eine karotte 27
eine kuriose einen rotor bin zwar ein
paar basilikumblätter 50 milliliter
olivenöl zehn gramm butter etwas pfeffer
einen sehr sozial
eine prise zucker einen esslöffel
tomatenmark und zwei lorbeerblätter
etwas wasser oder rotwein 800 gramm
tomaten 200 gramm cocktailtomaten und
500 cabrio sind sie mir zuerst einmal
die auberginen und die werden jetzt in
zwei zentimeter große würfel geschnitten
dafür scheinen direkt und schnell zu
klein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die auberginen werden jetzt mit zwei
teelöffel salz bestreut so können sie
nämlich 30 minuten lang ziehen und die
flüssigkeit geht raus geht nicht nur die
flüssigkeit heraus sondern die
bitterstoffe mit ihnen eben auch wenn
das jetzt hier andere beide clubs stehen
und weil es das restliche gemüse andere
die karotte und staudensellerie und als
mich auf mein handeln
die zwiebeln kann ich schon mal anbraten
dafür gebe ich jetzt die hälfte das
olivenöl und die komplette butter in
einem topf und erwärmte jetzt auf mittel
vor hitze dann kommen die da gleich sein
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon
uns diese gemüse schneiden springsport
graf zu sanieren
[Musik]
hier kommen die gemüse würfel hebel
hinzu und ich nehme jetzt nicht die ganz
natürlich schade weil er die kinder mit
essen und bis hin zu den rest nehmen wir
aber später einfach auf unsere teller
mit braucht und das gemüse wird es etwa
fünf minuten mit angebraten
[Musik]
das gemüse ist schön angebraten und in
der zwischenzeit habe ich die
tomatensauce und dass die haut einfach
entfernt werden jetzt will ich hier noch
das tomatenmark ihn so wird es kurz
nicht gebraten und dann kann es mit den
tomaten ablöschen und wer möchte kann an
der stelle zum beispiel auch mit rotwein
ablöschen oder einfach gleichen rotwein
zufügen statt wasser jetzt lasse ich
gehe schon aufgeholt und gilt noch die
gewürze hinzu also salz und zucker
lorbeerblätter und etwas pfeffer
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier in rosmarin stenger
dazu und lasse jetzt 20 minuten
einkochen und bei bedarf für mich
einfach ein bisschen wasser
[Musik]
die suppe köchelt jetzt noch vor sich
hin
die auberginen habe ich jetzt bereit
abgewaschen und habe sich gut
ausgedrückt und hier fressen hier
olivenöl in einer beschichteten pfanne
erwärmt jetzt kommen die ober stehen
hier rein und werden rundherum
angebraten
das ganze etwas vier bis fünf minuten
[Musik]
die auberginen gebe ich jetzt mit soße
da kommen jetzt auch tomaten mit das so
und dann müsste es einfach mal probieren
und mit salz und pfeffer abschmecken und
in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt hier
schon mal die nudeln aufkochen
das heißt dass die wcs in massen
knuddeln rein und dann einfach nach
packungsanleitung kochen
[Musik]
die nudeln habe ich jetzt abgeschlossen
und die gebe ich jetzt direkt nicht für
so was wie könntest du aber auch gerne
mit was anderem anrichten also können
auch kartoffeln dazugeben oder auch noch
hier zum beispiel wenn man es jetzt für
die piloten entschieden weil die auch
mit sich super dazu warten jetzt einfach
mal kurz durch schulen und dann kam
serviert werden
perfekte messen
jetzt kann ich das essen servieren und
erlass steht schon bereit
ich glaube die menschen probieren genau
wie zum parmesan drüber ein bisschen
pfeffer und basilikum die entscheidung
ist ganz kurz mit der kräuter schwere
klein und fertig ist das leckere und vor
allem frische gericht er nicht mit der
hand gaben
das hast du die gäste sie war schon ein
schock
mama okay airways probleme hier ist
wahrscheinlich erst bestritten
für mich ist es das perfekte sommer
gericht denn die auberginen hat man im
garten die tomaten hat man im garten und
dann kann man das ding ist superschnell
vorbereiten
vor allem kann man es auch super einfach
vegan zu bereiten indem man die butter
weglässt und ein paar samen weg lässt
man kann aber auch wenn man möchte den
streifen dazu machen alles fleisch und
ella fritz langs auswegen gucke ich
gleich nach ihr
und falls ihr das nachmachen möchte dann
geht auf belize - los gehts noch mal
ganz genau und ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß und namen und bis zum nächsten
mal
ein anlass um zum kameramann sind
brauchen wir noch hatte kraft mit dem
mit der handlung an sein
[Musik]